c'était pour moi un choc très violent la
misère du prolétaire urbain devenu vieux
est obligé de tendre la main pour
survivre quand en 1959 le maire
socialiste de besançon jean minjoz
appelle henri aux affaires sociales ses
pour s'occuper des vieux lui dit il
déjà conseiller en 53 ce résistant franc
maçon a développé depuis longtemps sa
fibre humaniste et solidaire
il trouve alors un bureau de
bienfaisance trop limité sa fille et
vine ternant militante communiste garde
son action comme à robert indélébile le
choc pour lui ça a été l'aide
alimentaire c'est à dire le fait que ce
bureau de bienfaisance distribuer des
bons de pain des tickets de viande est
que ces personnes étaient ainsi
stigmatisés
[Musique]
le minimum social garanti nés en 68 sous
l'impulsion de review ne s'est pas
implanter sans mal au congrès nationale
des ccas à epinal l'adjoint au maire de
besançon avait été mis en minorité
même le calme ans ça n'a pas été simple
enfin le fallait se battre pour faire
accéder et ça c'était l'idée
fondamentale
tous les gens de besançon a les
ressources minimales qui l'heure
actuelle de la guinée au luttions contre
cette idée que ça n'était pas possible
financièrement
vous pouvez lui disais parfois oui mais
d'accord mais les ivrognes ils vont
aller boire une chopine devint le
minimum social garanti et il disait on
respecte la personne on l'aide par
ailleurs à sortir de ses addictions
mais on la respecte elle est digne et la
dignité
c'est un revenu monétaire
passer de l'aide en nature revenus
monétaires
je pense que c'était extrêmement
novateur novateur au point d'inspirer le
rmi le revenu minimum garanti créée en
1988 il faut quand même remarquer que le
rmi n'était pas à hauteur du minimum
social garanti puisque le msg minimum
social garanti et représenter 70 % du
smic alors que le rmi n'a pas été indexé
est représentée en gros 40 % du smic
cette résidence autonomie a été créé en
64 la deuxième de france en vidéo n'a
pas été l'initiateur mais le développeur
en lien avec auguste ponceau le
président du centre communal d'action
sociale de l'époque
ce concept c'était le fait que les
personnes puissent terminer leurs rêves
et leurs jours dans leurs meubles avec
le choix entre une autonomie totale
notamment se faire à manger ou alors au
contraire utiliser les services c'est à
dire les services de restauration les
multiples services médicaux que
reste-t-il aujourd'hui de l'action dans
rio des résidences autonomie pas encore
assez développé
et puis le rsa en lieu et place du rmi
et vie interne en le juge éloignés du
minimum social garanti le titulaire
serait cette fois ci seront redevables
vis-à-vis de la société posé l'existence
d'un droit c'est considérer que c'est la
société qui est redevable à l'égard de
la personne c'est un c'est une inversion
des droits et devoirs pour moi chez dell
le changement d'une société s'était
c'était un changement de civilisation
aussi jose lire et ça ne devrait pas de
cette dimension là
[Musique]